>> AUDIENCES ARE BUZZING ABOUT
"FIRE ISLAND," A NEW REALITY
SHOW ON LOGO ABOUT SIX SEXY GAY
GUYS SHARING A BEACH HOUSE.
>> COCKTAILS, SUNSHINE.
>> BOYS.
>> IT'S A GAY DISNEYLAND, Y'ALL.
>> AND IF YOU LIKE SEPARATING
TYPES OF PEOPLE INTO SHOWS,
YOU'LL LOVE LOGO'S OTHER NEW
REALITY SHOW, "CHERRY GROVE,"
ABOUT A GROUP OF AFFLUENT
LESBIANS, ONE BEACH AWAY.
[ BABIES CRYING ]
>> HEY BETH, DID YOU PACK MY
WATER SOCKS?
BETH?
>> SPEND A WEEKEND WITH THESE
SEXY STUDS.
>> 21, AND I'M THE CRAZY LITTLE
ONE.
>> AND THESE WOMEN.
>> I'M 38.
AND I'M THE DAIRY INTOLERANT
ONE.
>> GET READY FOR THE INSANE
PARTIES.
>> THIS WEEKEND I'M READY FOR
ANYTHING.
♪ WHY ♪
♪ LET'S GO DOWN TO THE WATER'S
EDGE ♪
>> IF YOU THINK "FIRE ISLAND" IS
NONSTOP SEX, WAIT 'TIL YOU SEE
WHAT PASSES FOR A BANGFEST IN
"CHERRY GROVE."
>> I JUST NEED YOU TO TELL ME
THAT YOU SEE ME.
>> I SEE YOU.
I SEE YOU.
[ WEEPING ]
>> THE BOYS MAY LOVE DRAMA --
>> ARE YOU [ BLEEP ] KIDDING ME?
>> I'M NOT GONNA ENTERTAIN THIS
[ BLEEP ] ANYMORE.
>> BUT WATCH THESE LADIES LOSE
IT.
>> HEY, HEY, HEY.
I THOUGHT WE SAID NO SCREENS.
>> YOUR RULES.
>> I JUST THINK IF WE BOTH AGREE
ON SOMETHING --
>> I DO AGREE, BUT WHEN YOU
HAMMER AND YOU HAMMER, IT'S HARD
TO BE IN LOVE WITH YOU.
>> I'M SORRY YOU FEEL LIKE I'M
HAMMERING.
>> SO GET READY FOR THE
RAUNCHIEST --
>> SHH, SHH, SHH.
>> CRAZIEST.
[ YELLING ]
>> THAT'S A WOLF SANCTUARY ALL
RIGHT.
>> GAYEST SUMMER YOU'VE EVER
HAD.
>> EXCUSE ME, SIR.
CAN YOU PLEASE LOWER YOUR JAZZ?
THERE ARE FIVE MIRACLES OF HOME
WATER BIRTH ASLEEP IN THIS
HOUSE.
>> IT'S ALMOST 9:00 P.M.
>> "CHERRY GROVE" COMING SOON ON
LOGO.
>> YAS, QUEEN, WORK QUEEN, YAS.